[Music]
ready to roll on the Rich Eisen show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
to San Francisco
Davonte Adams 160 receiving yards most
buy a Packers player in a playoff game
as called by the one and only Joe Buck
who was getting set along with Eggman to
call his sixth Super Bowl two weeks
after calling the Nash the NFC
Championship game on Fox this coming
Sunday between the Packers and the 49ers
I think I've covered it all Joe right
did I cover a roll man yeah that's it
it's about it I don't know what I what I
can add well thanks for coming on then
Joe that's all I would John for it's
just I would be bonding next to it that
was fun you get what you pay for you
know well done very very well I'm just
trying to just try to take care of my
chick yes and by that you mean actual
livestock though right Joe oh yeah I
live in st. Louis we all that's what we
all have just walking around the
background just taking care of the
chicken hey Joe I guess the here's
here's the here's here's my way to to uh
to turn it it sure looked like the
Packers took care of their chicken
yesterday against the yeah the Seahawks
don't you think yeah they did I you know
it was kind of a return to form I think
for Aaron Rodgers on some level I know
that he would bristle at that and I'm
sure he is tired of hearing about him
having it down here in fact when we
talked to him he was rather I don't want
to say defiant but quick to point out
that they were 13 and 3 and a number 2
seed and they're overlooked and
underappreciated and they're gonna sneak
up on people and then they went out and
did it and I thought Aaron Rodgers made
some of the typical great Aaron Rodgers
throws that he makes on third down and
that was really the story of the game
third down won it for Green Bay they won
that little mini battle and he made some
great throws especially the last two
that counted one to Davante Adams on the
sideline and one to Jimmy Graham with a
questionable spot but a first down
nonetheless and the game was over and
that's what the great ones do and that's
what he did
well you know and
no having spoken to so many players in
all the years that you have covered the
NFL with with Fox know that you will
come across a bunch of first ballot Hall
of Famers who will use the nobody
believes in us mantra and you do sit
there and roll your eyes like what are
you talking about
Brady just a couple years ago going off
to the Superbowl saying nobody believes
in this essentially however you got a I
don't blame Rodgers for being pissed the
guy's 13 and 3 right this team was one
Jacob Hollister reception inch away from
being the 1 seed throughout the entire
NFC playoffs and everybody's same and
he's kind of an old dog who can't learn
any new tricks and who's this new
first-time head coach and yet they're
heading off to the NFC Championship game
I don't blame them for beat bristling
right no III agree with that
and I've seen just too many times Aaron
Rodgers literally take a game over you
know people that you know all facts
Packer fans think that Troy and I hate
the Packers which is ridiculous and we
always joke about this but I think the
rest of the country gets tired of us
just throwing bouquets Aaron Rodgers but
he's just different
and he's been different since he took
over in 2008 I think he does it in maybe
a little different fashion now he
doesn't use his legs as much but he uses
his legs to get his body out of the
pocket and be able to contort and make a
throw from any angle
to any part of the field and so yeah
I've I've admired him over the years and
I think he's one of the great ones and
he is definitely one of those players
that uses whatever anybody says is per
personal motivation and you know however
it needs to get done he usually gets it
done he's been a two-time MVP on a Super
Bowl and there one went away from from
going back and then I read a column
today getting ready for the game on
Sunday from the coverage of the 49ers
that acts like the Packers shouldn't
even show up and Rodgers is over the
hill and cooked and I just I just don't
see that well the 38 to 7 went on Sunday
night where the Packers coming off of a
bye week back in week 12 is probably
fuel for that fire that's probably
that's no doubt and
there's good reason why they write it I
just think that you know since that game
they haven't lost Green Bay and I just
don't expect that same kind of game they
were coming off a bye they were off from
the beginning they turned the ball over
right at the start and the game was
pretty much finished before it even
began I just don't see that happening
now I you know San Francisco is favored
by whatever it is seven points for a
reason if they're getting healthy
finally on the offensive line on the
defense they showed what they could do
they shut down Minnesota they're their
the top seed and they're the best team
in the NFC and they're in that that
driver's seat but Green Bay will show up
and Aaron Rodgers will play a good
ballgame I would be shocked if he
doesn't yeah I agree with you on that I
truly cannot wait for that but you're
right the 49ers what they did that front
seven I mean that front four I got D
Ford coming up shortly and Nick Bosa
said after the game that he's kind of
jealous that he wishes he had the
ability to just on site make people
afraid like d4 does and he came back
there they're amazing
up front yeah they I mean he basically
missed the last five games with a bad
hamstring board and he comes back and
kind of sets the whole thing up but I
have a feeling that Nick doses being a
little bit modest and humble I'm sure
that there are offensive linemen that
are not thrilled about facing Doce
either so they're good up front they're
good in the middle now they got
Alexander back at linebacker they're
good at the secondary share mark out or
Sherman got his third career postseason
pick I mean and the safeties are good so
I I don't know I mean there they are the
full meal deal on offense defense
special teams is better than it was
earlier in the year they've got a kicker
that's been there and done it and Robbie
gold so they they are gonna be hard to
be Joe Buck here in the Rich Eisen show
what's the floor like I've never spoken
him variable yeah honest to god I when
we hang up with him or walk out of a
meeting room with him we all kind of
look at each other like man he is he's
not paranoid and he would think that a
first-year guy that's a great one
talking to people
you know that are covering the game
would be really secretive about what
they're cooking up in the back room for
that week's opponent and he lays it all
out and he's honest and he gives you a
real opinion on the way guys are playing
you know I talked to him about the
numbers for for Aaron Rodgers being down
and he said yeah well we have to do a
better job a Colin plays B get the more
playmakers because basically it's been
three guys it's been Aaron Rodgers
Davante Adams and Aaron Jones and that
was pretty much the case yesterday and
and we would be remiss we didn't point
out the job that Russell Wilson did
because there are times where it's just
like him doing it on his own and that's
not to slight anybody else on that
offense but I just don't see anybody
able to do what he does and almost
single-handedly willing his team to get
into a position to win I mean week in
and week out all he's done is win since
coming into the NFL so I thought he
played a tremendous game with a depleted
offensive line and you know the running
back situation they lost their top three
running backs and they were still in
that game on the road in the cold till
the end I I think the guy is just a
tremendous winner he is I want to put a
pin in Russell Wilson for a second no
one returned to Lafleur because the
relationship between Rogers and Lafleur
would be should the Packers make the
Superbowl a top five storyline for the
week I mean we will be picking that
whole storyline apart like crazy leading
up to your call with Troy of that of
that game what have you seen what have
you personally witnessed about this and
can actually report what's real and
what's not these guys yeah well I mean
for as honest as Matt Lafleur has been
with us this year aaron has always been
brutally honest over the years with us
you know I know that he he respects and
trusts Troy and and I think he's willing
to tell us exactly how he feels some
things we share some things we don't
over the years and with the previous
regime and and you know other players
that have been there but I get the sense
that he is genuinely pleased and happy
with the way that has all evolved and I
think he almost heads it off the
questioning at the
ass with jumpin at us when you start
going down that road of you know why
aren't the numbers typical Aaron Rodgers
number the numbers I think he completed
62 percent of his passes have had that
you know down the stretch wasn't that
accurate had a rough game at Detroit but
they got the win and that's the most
important thing and and he just that's
why he cuts it off I think he is happy
and I think he he's at a different stage
in his career and he'd rather win and
pile up huge stats and I I think that's
where they are I don't think either ones
hold it back at least with us behind
closed doors or on a conference call I
think they they have a lot of
appreciation for each other and nanoq
the play calling last night was
fantastic with being able to get to
Monta Adams the whole stadium knows that
that's the guy that Rodgers is looking
for singled up and and open really
throughout the entire game and on that
big third down what about it the most on
that final drive so then what's the
PostScript on the Seahawks for 2019
because it is so tough to transition
from championship ears here and then
build another one there same quarterback
same guy in the middle of the defense
essentially same guy in the headset and
that's about it what's the PostScript on
this team trying to get to the Final
Four well I just think that they've had
a tough time with their offensive line
even when they were rolling it had a lot
of moving parts they had you know they
lost their Center this year they lost
ethan posix for the majority of the year
on IR they lost their top three running
backs if they get healthy there they
still have Russell Wilson I think it
goes back to the offensive line and it's
been two straight years of wilt dis Lee
their tight end who's a really talented
player and a guy they love ending the
season on IR and defensively they they
have some holes in the secondary they
still have Bobby Wagner and KJ right in
that at that middle level and Bobby
Wagner's and all-pro so they're there's
a lot of pieces there they have a really
smart good GM and the young receiver who
we haven't even talked about DKMS county
we picked it all up
Aston is a physical specimen and runs
a43 so there's a lot there to like and
you know a tweak here a tweak there I
just don't think he'd get past looking
at the offensive line that's got to get
better the hell should be back with the
running backs and and I think they'll be
right back you know looking to get into
the final four a year last one for you
Joseph what a great moment with Jimmy
Johnson getting the the call from the
Hall on live television just similar to
obviously Bill Cowher
on CBS the day before this one however
is obviously personal for the guy that
you stand next to for all of these games
what a great moment when they cut
Detroit with tears in his eyes watching
it from the booth in Lambeau were you
right there or yeah I I backed up and
let the let the camera shoot him because
that's the relationship I've gotten Oh
Jimmy over the years and and loved the
guy to death but right but I think
Terry's reaction was just as was just as
real with the way he you know was
cheering I I don't know that all those
guys knew what was going to happen I
know the producer bill Richards knew
that David Baker was going to walk in
there and tell Jimmy we were alerted to
it to stick around because I think they
wanted instead of us run into the
bathroom or whatever they yeah they kept
Troy on headset and and I think we we
surmised that it would be that
announcement
especially after Cour the day before so
it was really you know that there's a
lot of love there and Jimmy is beloved
at Fox but then you go back obviously to
the early nineties Cowboys and what
Jimmy's meant to Troy what tournament to
Jimmy there's so much respect and you
know that was it was good to see from
both I think all of us if we were taking
bet would have thought that Jimmy would
not cry and if he watched that not only
did he cry but he was literally choked
up and I just think it's a relief and
it's a pat on the back and well deserved
I mean he is his importance to the
league is felt to this day and and what
he brought in and how he made the
Cowboys relevant again when he was hired
by Jerry Jones it's great stuff you only
get one call from the hall man and that
that's just like it's it that
only happens once and that was neat to
see and it was great to see Troy's
natural reaction he's good people as you
know Joe so are you and I'm not just
saying that cuz you called into my show
you know that
well thanks rich I Milwaukee I'm gonna
walk a little taller today you know you
should you should you're gonna hang with
those kiddos and then head off to the
Bay Area right that's pretty good for
next few days that's that's the next few
days get my kid time in color those
little boys I see it on your Twitter on
your obviously Michels Instagram and not
yours that's private and I'm pleased to
get past the the gates there oh those
little boys Joseph they're great they're
they're hooked on I was gone for three
days more days and I came back and now
they're hooked on dinosaurs so I kind of
raised girls yes my first go-around with
this I might my will whatever one and a
half 20 month old kids now know more
about the classification of dinosaurs
than I do so I have to I have to
actually study hmm what the hell a
Stegosaurus is compared to a
brontosaurus compared to a I know what a
velociraptor is because of the movie
Jurassic Park and then a t-rex that's
about where it is for man Joe my guys
are laughing cuz I've never seen
Jurassic Park that's part of my pop
culture on blind-spot yep never seen it
that's impossible it's possible because
I have never seen it I know it's
possible it's just sad I know the
dinosaurs had come alive I get it
I understand and they move in herds
what's the big deal they do move it or I
don't mean to offend Joe Joe but you
don't want to suspend disbelief huh you
don't want to you don't want to get
wrapped up and Newman from Seinfeld
that's part of it no that's true I'm
sorry I blew the whole movie that's the
big end he's all sweaty and driving and
he can't see out of his windshield and
then he gets eaten and then the movie
ends Wow roll credits
yeah all right Joe I'll see you in Miami
I will see you shortly okay you pack
your uh you pack your shorts and your
sandals and your sock and we'll see you
there
that will
do that I will I will show up dressing
like the film of the Flamingo kid
that's how I'll be good I've seen odd
buck at at buck on Twitter for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app